-As you guys know, we're always
striving to get better
here at "The Tonight Show."
♪ Harder, better,
faster, stronger ♪
Which is why we asked
viewers at home
to send in
any suggestions that they have
just to get some feedback about
what you guys think of the show,
things you'd like to see us do,
that kind of stuff.
So tonight, let's look inside
the audience suggestion box.
-♪ Look into the box,
the suggestion box ♪
-Here we go here. This first one
is from Owen Sheckart.
"Hey, Jimmy, I like watching
'The Bachelor,'
but some parts of it
are too emotional for me.
You should fix that."
Well, we always take
our suggestions seriously here.
So here's an emotionally intense
scene from "The Bachelor"
re-voiced with the least
emotional person we know, Siri.
Take a look.
-I'm sorry that
I hurt your feelings.
Thank you.
I accept your apology,
but I think that we have
very different realities
of what occurred.
Regardless of what happened --
Well, if it didn't happen,
why are you apologizing?
Matt had mentioned
that you think I'm toxic
and manipulative.
I do think you're those things.
I don't want
to continue fighting.
I'm not trying to fight, either,
but I think that, like,
we are like oil and vinegar.
-Wow. [ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
I'd watch a whole episode
of that, man. I like that.
Let's get to another
suggestion here.
This is from Liza Geller.
"Hey, Jimmy. You're always
asking guests questions.
You should try asking the camera
a question."
Try asking
the camera a question?
That's a great idea.
I guess I can give it a shot.
Okay, Camera, do you work
at "The Tonight Show"?
Oh.
Do you like working at the show?
Can you tell us your favorite
person in the studio?
Come on, Camera.
Show us your favorite person
in the studio.
We all want to know.
Tha--
Wait, what?
Wait, what --
What the hell?
-Come on!
-What the --
-Do this!
-Who let this guy in here?
-Eat [bleep] [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That guy's a menace.
That guy's a menace right there.
-Nice [bleep] studio!
[Bleep] hole!
[ Laughter, applause ]
At least he's wearing a mask.
Alright. This next one here
is from Michelle Pirozi.
"Hey, Jimmy. I love
'Bridgerton.'"
Me, too.
"It has such a good theme song,
but I wish it had lyrics.
Could you add some?"
That's a great idea.
Tariq, Quest, you guys
want to take this one?
-You got it.
-Sure.
[ "Bridgerton"
theme song playing ]
-♪ Old timey people
with cool sideburns ♪
-♪ Who like to dance ♪
-♪ Old timey people
wearing wigs ♪
-♪ And fancy pants ♪
-♪ They're riding horses now ♪
-♪ And drinking tea ♪
-♪ They're also
eating crumpets ♪
-♪ Everyone is British ♪
-♪ Old timey people
with cool sideburns ♪
-♪ And fancy pants ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Neither of you have ever seen
the show, have you?
-Not at all.
-Nay.
-Let's get another
suggestion here.
Oh, this one is from
Vivian Zelter.
"Hey, Jimmy, you should
advertise more products
on the show."
That's an interesting suggestion
but it just doesn't feel right
to do an ad
in the middle of the show.
I mean, just thinking about it
leaves a bad taste in my mouth,
unlike...Paul Leonard's
Edible Calculators,
the first nonfunctional,
fully digestible calculators.
I just crunched the numbers,
and...they're delicious.
Now with even less mercury!
♪♪
[ Applause ]
Okay. We're down to
our last suggestion here.
It is from Matt Gilberg.
"Hey, Jimmy.
I know there are a lot of shows
that film in New York City.
So I was wondering, do you ever
visit any of the other shows?"
Well, it's funny you ask that,
because I do.
It's all thanks to my TV portal.
Yeah.
The TV portal can put me...
[ Whoosh ]
...in any other New York show.
Let me show you.
-We have a great show
for you guys.
I'm really excited!
Oh! Jimmy. You okay?
-[ Weakly ] Hi, Drew.
-Okay.
-Oh, God.
-Well, that's
all the time we have
for "Audience Suggestion Box."
Stick around, everyone,
and we'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪